a sad story from the Daily Mail Mitch
McConnell freezes again Republican
senator 81 Sparks health concerns by
suddenly stopping for 30 seconds I'm
gonna play for you uh this video and
it's very strange
and let's make sure we have the uh
check this out
I'm sorry I had a hard time hearing you
that's okay what are your thoughts on
running for re-eleven
what are my thoughts about what running
for re-election in 2018.
not sure
he's gone did you hear the question
Senator running for reelection in 2026
yes he went he went yes the response
that was a question I'm sorry we're
gonna need a minute
did you keep playing If this just gets
crazier
he's not incapacitated I think they're
trying to move him with us yeah he's
look at his hands on the podium he's
holding on he's gripping because he's
gonna fall over look how hard he's
holding onto the podium he's trying not
to collapse somebody else have a
question please speak up this guy's
stroking out
it wasn't look at it look at him holding
on he's about to fall and she's holding
his back
she can't get his arm off the podium
yeah
terrible
[Music]
whoa the moving his head around and he's
looking it's not a stroke that's not
what a stroke looks like he's he's I
think his blood pressure may be dropping
he may be about to pass out where is
anybody trying to help him I'd be so
concerned if I was standing there
[Music]
Daniel Cameron uh you have a comment on
Daniel Cameron
very close
[Music]
dude he's Friday he's out he's out of
there
why would they leave him there because
they don't want to show the camera that
he's sick I don't think so the craziest
point is this when she's a question
Senator running for re-election in 2026
okay yes but it doesn't answer it I know
just yes like whoa and then his hands
holding on for dear life he was holding
himself up he's he looks like he has
full-blown dementia to me and and I yeah
I worked in skilled nursing homes for a
decade and that's what it looks like
it's the same thing Joe Biden does he
does the same crap he's sundowning it's
he's like oh and probably the the uh uh
bursts of Rage yes that Joe Biden does
and the ice cream right the ice cream
man we used to give patients ice cream
when when they started having their
sundowning moment towards the evening
give them ice cream and they'd forget
all about it and so I see the guy with
the ice cream and I'm like he's
sundowning man yeah he's got dementia
he's sundowning there's no so there was
that famous video where Joe Biden snaps
at the reporter or whatever who asks
about I forgot the issue he's like jobs
it was job jobs yelling yeah and it's uh
what I was told is people who are
suffering from dementia no they can't
know like they're cognizant of the
failing a question was asked of me and I
can't put it together and it's
frustrating being unable and so they get
really angry and just go throw on they
have these outbursts
sometimes violently right they get
really angry this is the weakest I've
ever seen a politician in the United
States have you seen Feinstein yeah
they're all they're all she's like in a
wheelchair like barely alive yeah yeah
she's like they're carting around she
gave power of attorney to her daughter
and she's just being wheeled around and
they're they're like now that you're
back are you gonna watch like I never
left it's like ma'am you've been gone
for a long time I will say that uh I've
seen a lot more politicians looking
bad yeah over the last couple years than
I've ever seen the old days my entire
life uh or you know maybe they're
adrenal Supply right now I wonder if
clothing messed people up the Old Guard
doesn't want to let go of power the old
guy I don't know if this is like this
like I'm younger here I don't know if
like in the 80s and 70s we saw something
similar of these older politicians that
wouldn't let go I never saw that I
didn't give public speeches like this
yeah what would the founding fathers
have us do uh I don't know you know I
think the issue is Mitch McConnell is
just uh he he's he's waiting for the
Genesis device to be repaired in the
basement the Capitol Building to
rejuvenate him back to a youthful 20. I
think it'll then masquerade as an intern
what a loser to think that this is what
the most important thing in his life
what do you what do you mean by what are
the what would they do if they had a guy
with dementia in Congress like go home
man go home would they grab him and pull
them out of there and be like you're not
allowed back in I don't imagine no
that's not true there's a bunch of
politicians who are whacked out there
was like a Supreme Court Justice who was
out of his mind there's nothing like if
you want to know all you got to do is
look in the Constitution like there are
methods to take people to remove people
from Office impeachment and stuff like
all like there's a lot of times where
like people are like oh well what would
they do it's like all of the questions
can be answered by reading the
Constitution so if someone gets dementia
you impeach them well you you could just
write the answers in there if the
president was 25 25th amendment or
something like that but there's there's
recalls there's there's a way to do I
don't know if it's it might not
technically be an impeachment because I
think that's actually the trial to
remove them up from office so there
might there's others indictment yeah
okay so so it probably wouldn't be
called an impeachment but it'd be some
there are definitely methods to get
people that are in that are
incapacitated or cannot fulfill the
office there are methods that the
founders had to take them out of office
it's just that there needs to be an
appetite for it among the population and
among the people that are actually in
power that means people have to get in
touch with their Congress people and
their senators and be like hey or
whatever if it's just Congress it might
be maybe it's just a congress person or
whatever but you didn't get in touch
with them be like hey this is a problem
for me I'm a constituent and this is a
problem for me so until people actually
act nothing will happen I will say that
correlation is not causation but I have
seen a lot more uh politicians like this
since the demise of Jeffrey Epstein for
sure so
could be Andreina Chrome thanks
now that Epson shuts down Mitch is like
I mean we're watching politicians do
stuff like this on a daily basis I'm
like you know they know it's not now
hold on there a minute you realize Media
Matters are going to take what you just
said seriously that's okay and then it's
going to be in the independent and the
daily I said I want to I want to be very
clear about my presidential campaign
this is we're running a very serious
campaign but I'm I'm the first
libertarian that's going to tell you as
a as a candidate for a Libertarian
president that I am not going to win the
presidency okay I'm not under any
illusion they're going to let us in the
white house we want five percent to
change the political landscape what is
America what does it do gives us
National major party status it will
include us in the debates in the next
election it makes us have it makes the
federal government have to do all the
same things for the Republicans and
democrats for the Libertarians as well
and then you run like a superstar yeah
and then we run a superstar they get in
the debates you know we then we start we
start being a party that someone can
trust so I'm not going to come out here
and lie to everybody and be like whoa
any any libertarian candidate that's
telling you he's going to win the
presidency this year is a liar or
suffering from delusions of grandeur I
mean we're we're my goal is five percent
change the political landscape for the
rest of
Eternity in the United States make
another a national political party then
you have a a candidate that's actually
circling the waters making these people
have to start
um uh uh governing like they campaign
everything's different after that
everything what's the difference between
running a third party and running
independent
uh third so third so we fought for
ballot access as Libertarians already
we're gonna get on the ballot um and our
party will have we'll be on about at
least 40 something States um we may not
get all 50 this year because we don't
have the money but the fact that there's
already it's just a lot of money is a
cost uh so it just depends there's some
states that are really bad like uh
Tennessee needs like 200 000 signatures
to get on the ballot we've been fighting
Tennessee but ballot access laws for
ever since I've been in the party since
like 2010.
um New York is very hard uh Alabama has
been very hard uh some states we have it
already and it's easy and some states we
get it by running a smaller down ballot
candidates that get a certain percentage
and we've gotten it that way so you need
signatures not necessarily money
signatures and or money yeah or money or
one or the other some some states are
like that some states are just
signatures what about taking over a
state uh New Hampshire is has been
working on that for a long time and I
think it's I think it's a I I love the
free state project I think those guys
have done a lot of really great stuff
there I don't know I'm sure Phil would
agree in some ways right I think they're
doing great things yeah I endorse the I
endorse the free state project for sure
I think that's a very smart idea I
talked about doing it in Iowa too I
think that Iowa's a very very very uh
conservative Liberty loving State too
West Virginia is but it's got to be
cleaned up yes there's a lot of red tape
we didn't send a single Democrat to
Washington from from Iowa not one wow
not a single one you're welcome America
yeah I feel like uh West Virginia is
ready to have a big evolution yes yeah
it was it was a it was a Democrat state
for a long time uh what was it Riley
Moore we've had him on the show several
times he's the first Republican
Treasurer so he's been Democrat yeah
he's fantastic any skates skateboards
nice okay nice
yeah super cool it would be cool to have
some sort of power in the in the state
government
I don't care about political power uh
you know it is it is interesting running
a show like this and and knowing as many
people as I do
because it's it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's it's an interesting
perspective that I did not have when I
was younger when it comes to the idea of
like lobbying and how this stuff works
like quite literally there are there are
people who are in office that will come
on this show and have a conversation
with me and those exchange of ideas can
influence laws and other parts it's like
it's really it's really that simple
often you know just literally talking to
a politician then they can draft
something and they can change things
West Virginia has I think like 1.5 or so
million people maybe it's 1.6 maybe it's
1.3 I'm not sure so it actually is
substantially easier in a state like
West Virginia or even New Hampshire
where the population is
smaller than West Virginia I believe
right or right around the same but I
during covet I went down to the state
house there and lobbied with these guys
I got interviews I did interviews with
Paul like state legislators we have uh
great state legislature that's why I
want to do uh the Martinsburg project
yes it's like I'm not going to go for a
state I'm just gonna go for like a very
small City County and uh uh well it's
Berkeley County okay yeah and then
Martinsburg is the uh is the town but
we've got properties in West Virginia in
Jefferson and Berkeley County so this is
the Eastern Panhandle you've got
basically what's happening is uh what I
would describe as a woke incursion this
is Maga country unquestionably right now
where we do the studio we're actually in
Maryland and because we operate out of
the Tri-State which is Maryland Virginia
West Virginia but we're setting up all
the new studio stuff all the new stores
everything is going to be in West
Virginia it is in West Virginia and what
we're finding is that the locals who are
in these towns are getting increasingly
frustrated with the people from DC who
are coming out here and masquerading as
Maga but secretly trying to implement
woke and communist policies and Marxism
and stuff like that we saw it in local
schools the people would run for school
board and be like we want you know
church and Faith and family and then as
soon as they get in they'd be like all
right bring in all the weird you know
porn and everything for the kids
Heretics for sure yeah I mean call my
heretic but like it's just they're
subversives they're masquerading as
right you know we we're locals here and
we want to do good and then the way they
do they have drag shows with with
children in West Virginia so my my
thought is like as long as we're here
and we're investing I encourage
everybody to come out to uh Martinsburg
Berkeley County and what we'll do is
effectively the free city project where
we just will help Revitalize a small
town yeah there's there's Legacy
families who have businesses there
they're great grandparents founded and
passed down to them who have been
complaining about how this wokeness
keeps creeping in they're seeing signs
everywhere these events are popping up
and they feel like they're losing I've
had City councilmen say they're they're
passing these Pride resolutions against
the wishes of the Town thousands of
people come out in protest but it
doesn't matter because they still sneak
in and start passing these things and
I'm like then we need to tell them no
yeah that's the Communist Playbook man I
mean right they've been they've been
telling us they were going to do these
things for years and years and years
decades Generations almost like having a
centralized place where people go and
sign some papers to affect everyone else
is defunct
right
it's it's just
we have so much respect uh the the
um the constitutional republic
Republicans and I don't mean Republican
political party I mean those who believe
in the constitutional republic all
Americans are Republicans they are not
we all are of the Republic there are
four Republican yes we are that is
incorrect because right now in places
like Charlestown and in Martinsburg in
in smaller Port other other areas in
West Virginia you have Multicultural
Democrats people who believe that the
system should not be run by a
constitution but by the the 50 50.1
percent majority and so and and also
it's not even about democracy and a
great deal it's about we are the better
people who can who should rule over you
yes so they lie to get power and then
they vote for things against the wishes
of the public to the consternation and
protest and they don't care and the only
way you change it is if you get
organized and we have say like a free
city project and we kind of I feel like
say push back I interrupted you you were
talking about centralized government in
the Republic public and uh because I
think it's a bad I think sending people
to a building somewhere to go sign
paperwork to affect everybody else well
I cut you off and said that we're all
Republican because we live in a
republican to carry on what I'm talking
about you have marxists people who
believe in the concept of what they call
Multicultural democracy and you have
people who believe in constitutional
republicanism the people who are in West
Virginia for the most part see their
City members of the city council I
shouldn't say all of West Virginia can I
talk about where I'm at and they passed
in Charlestown a pride resolution
recognizing pride month
everyone's pissed off they had a massive
uh uh protest all of these people
protesting marching but how do they
protest they silently pray as they March
the city but the people on the council
don't care all they care about is
getting that political power so you have
all of these people who are really angry
about what's going on and they live
there but they respect the idea of the
constitutional republic so they don't do
anything out of line they simply say
well we better vote next time what are
the marxists and the Multicultural uh
democracists whatever they call them
doing saying just keep lying to them
because we're smarter than they are and
then we can make change and the cops
will do as we said tactics for sure and
it's hands down thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time